esta partida importa Porque ambas
selecciones están clasificadas a la
próxima edición de la copa del mundo por
lo que estos dos seleccionadores estarán
probando algunas jugadoras y también
esquemas de cara lo que van a conseguir
en la máxima cita orbital que tendrá
como sede Australia y Nueva Zelanda para
Francia tiene especial interés este
partido porque marca el inicio del
técnico renald como director técnico del
combinado a pocos meses de lo que será
la Copa del Mundo tras la designación
para sustituir al entrenador a
corintiacre destituida por la federación
francesa de fútbol ante una disputa con
algunas jugadoras de la selección Pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo Crash
lloro una de las jugadoras del combinado
francés
es un partido importante para nosotras
pero también para el director técnico
porque es su primer partido también
porque es un bonito equipo Colombia es
uno de los equipos que ha venido
creciendo están en un mundial Así que no
hay que dejarlas de lado si están ahí es
por algo ahora Estamos al principio el
comienzo de esta aventura y tenemos que
prepararnos bien y esto va a comenzar
desde este viernes en la noche
prepararnos gracias a este tipo de
partidos para el resto Y por supuesto
que lo vamos a jugar con mucho empeño
por su parte Colombia ASUME el reto con
miras a desarrollar tácticas para
enfrentar las elecciones de alto nivel
no obstante en el país sudamericano
sigue la preocupación por el poco tiempo
de la liga profesional que este año
tendrá solo unos meses sobre ello habló
la integrante del seleccionado Daniela
Montoya
este año entiendo que por por
compromisos de Copa Libertadores no se
logró hacer todo el año pero que es algo
que sí o sí necesitamos tener esa
competencia continua y que seguramente
se va a dar el otro año y más que nada
porque necesitamos seguir ese proceso de
esa evolución del fútbol femenino la
conmebol digamos
ha evolucionado muchísimo también en el
fútbol femenino vemos que que hay muy
buenas condiciones en cuanto a los
premios económicos y eso es importante
para los clubes Entonces eso hace que
haya más inversión